my daddy
no that's my daddy he was both of your
daddy wasn't he for phoebe and isabel
photographs help keep the memory of
their father alive
who is it it's daddy
the girl's parents laura and ryan would
have been married by now the wedding was
due to take place this month had ryan
not being killed in a car crash nearly
two years ago
it's almost archaic
and you know the idea that you have to
have it on paper you have to be
legally married
to be entitled to anything like that
the department for work and pensions
have told laura only people who've
legally tied the knot are eligible for
bereavement support payments amounting
to hundreds of pounds a month and data
shared with sky news suggests tens of
thousands of children are missing out
leaving families struggling after the
loss of a partner's income
without the support i've had from family
i'd have been sinking
and what does that mean thinking to you
bill's being unpaid rent being unpaid no
food in
sorry the memory of trying to make ends
meet remains painful for siobhan
mclaughlin it's eight years since her
partner of 23 years john died from
cancer siobhan held down three jobs to
support their four children
an emotional rollercoaster
i have cried
in 2018 siobhan took the uk government
to court for discrimination and won but
four years on the law still hasn't been
changed
i honestly did think that the government
would have said you know we hold our
hands up but we're really sorry that we
kind of did just forget about these
children
and we're going to rectify it and we're
going to rectify it as soon as possible
but they didn't
whether someone is married or not is
irrelevant the liberal democrat leader
ed davey who lost both his parents by
the age of 15 is supporting campaigners
who say they're being ignored by the
government they just don't give any
answers
it's just like how can they be so cruel
you know that this is this is real
people's lives and and children
that are suffering
will there be no further delay
two and a half years ago the issue was
raised in parliament and more promises
made that haven't yet been kept
we will do what we can to remedy it just
take the party points out of it
this is actually about children who've
lost their mum or their dad
i think it's a total scandal
um i think
the media should be reporting this and
shouting about it from the tops of the
ruse this is a government failure on
extraordinary scale
the government says it hopes to make
changes as soon as parliamentary time
allows and will back date payments but
for some parents already struggling with
grief the fight for bereavement support
goes on lisa holland sky news